[Musique]
jocelyn bruno alliés dramatique je suis
très content de vous rencontrer parce
que vous êtes un pionnier du rap
québécois entre autres avec le groupe
mondial on va y revenir mais avant je
veux parler de votre projet royauté
c'est une compilation de douze chansons
écrites et réalisées par une trentaine
d'artistes issus des communautés noires
du québec vous avez amassé 100 mille
dollars que vous allez remettre au fond
1800 à 0,4 pour la persévérance scolaire
et pourquoi avoir choisi de soutenir la
persévérance scolaire souvent mais on
voit les crêpes on en a pas des
ressources la table dans le dos et à
cette époque là à l'âge de 15 ans au
secondaire mouvement je me rappelle le
temps manque de ressources puisque je
n'en entends besoin d'une passerelle
vers le monde du plein emploi si on a un
grave problème du temple d'employabilité
donc je pense que tout
cet arrangement est
bénéfique quoi votre carrière a commencé
il ya environ 25 ans dans le quartier
montréal-nord voici à l'école henri
bourassa
vous avez déjà dit en tant que bègue
c'est l'europe qui m'a libéré parce que
j'étais timide et dépressif comment le
rap vous à aider l'europe m'a aidé à
mettre des mots ensemble sans que je
m'en charge dedans parce que ce sont le
rap comme moi vous remarqué que
plusieurs célèbres parce que c'est de
passer par l'import en même temps puis
le rap est venu promettre une grille le
rap est venu mais d'avoir plus de
confiance en moi le rap a mené l'europe
change de servir si juste le fait de
faire la moue extractives des plus
partie de ce qui s'en vient c'est pas
rien ça leur a pas changé votre vie au
soviba oui je pense que oui oui parce
qu'à cette époque-là en 89 j'ai trois
ans une époque sombre appartement à
l'âge de 16 17 ans avec des amis pyrite
chamakh des mauvais coups tout ça même
et leurs appuis veut mettre sur la
grille et ça qu'ils m'ont vraiment idéal
nous ne pas arrêter le
type de thérapie en soit j'ai pu mettre
tout mon tout mais des monstres 500
feuilles blanches
demain ouais démons des cris des drames
des traumatismes des
des stigmates qui m'habitait depuis
l'époque de
jeu n'est pas du tout quoi démontrer nos
dépendance au système dit votre carrière
a vraiment décollé en 1996 avec maud
zayan deux albums extraordinaire j'en
gagne le réflexe de l'année à l'adisq
que retenez vous de l'expérience mais je
retiens l'école en fait c'est fait une
vraie école qui est noir époque là on
vient d'une époque parce que il ya
vieille alcott des gens qui meurent
droit semblait donc le chemin était pas
encore tracé encore on était un système
d'alarmé devant la sirène et feux
automatiques vont attendre peut aborder
des problèmes très intelligent qui même
à des problèmes en dessous du tapis dans
le choix s'est fait pour josi gens qui
ont écouté les led lighting ont aussi
écouté mais des petits morceaux comme un
brillant rien à perdre c'est un hasard
donc ils ont tous vu que ce musée classe
et la musique des gens qui se manifeste
tout au long de votre carrière vous avez
manifesté contre la racisme le système
que je pense particulièrement de
chansons l'oubli et révolte vert comment
voulez vous parler d'un sujet aussi
sensible
et comment ne pas en parler
on se fait piquer on souffre on se brûle
et je dis qu'il faut que ça soit quelque
part on garde les manifestations on
dirait qu'on est encore à l'époque de 10
de marge en noir et blanc ce même
message ces phénomènes picken mêmes
manifestations c'est
[Musique]
une onde finalement de faire c'est extra
travail là je pourrais accepter en vrai
qu'on doit s'excuser de vivre puis
d'être là je sais que ça aujourd'hui
c'est un en soit l'important
gc ca on vous a vu dans l'excellente
série je voudrais qu'on m'efface on vous
a vu à l'écran commande devait trouver
expérience c'était juste génial moi même
de mon vivant je n'aurais jamais osé
demandeur un rôle parlant c'est rare
qu'on voit des becs à la petite
télévision comparé de
2,2 diversité bien ce sens sans motif il
ya plein plein de gens qui sont des
campeurs deux groupes prend la parole la
volonté de partager mon expérience est
plus forte que la voix de plus la peur
qui m'habite alors je fonce vous voulez
juste à m'inspirer des jeunes à fond
c'est parce que vous faites des ateliers
dans les écoles oui c'est ça qu'avez
vous à dire aux jeunes
aux jeunes de jeu diront jeunes de
croire en soi de ne pas arrêter des fois
on en est désolé dans notre tête qui est
dangereux qu'il faut continuer à nourrir
cette flamme là et c'est vous qui avez
loison finale
j'espère qu'ils ont entendu ouais
dramatique mais pas beaucoup
les garderies me rejette gelé compris
même les tartines britos becker j'essaye
de dire mon son pdg mais mais mais mais
comme c'est dit andré